hey leute und willkommen zu einem
kleinen faq was ich mal machen wollte da
ich immer und immer wieder die gleichen
fragen per pn und per e mail zugesendet
bekommen und ich das jetzt einfach mal
in einem video alles abhaken wollte so
dass jeder ein paar antworten drauf
bekommt und mir nicht immer das gleiche
schreibt also ich würde sagen wir fangen
auch direkt an und zwar die erste frage
die somit am häufigsten kommt ist kann
ich nicht bei skype enden bzw hier
gucken meine eltern mich mal oder wie
heißt du da oder bist du wirklich der
kontrakt bei skype ist erstmal ich habe
einen privaten skype nahm den keiner von
euch bekommen soll das möchte ich auch
nicht weil es gab es für mich privat ich
hab da private leute mit denen ich halte
da mache ich halt von youtube keine
wirklich private leute und also privat
meine ich jetzt im sinne von ich kenne
die ich skype oft mit denen und so
weiter also nicht nur so bei youtube
nachrichten schreiben sondern schon so
aktiv und da habe ich auch leute die ich
irgendwie aus der schule kennen
das heißt mit den ich dann irgendwie
maske wenn wir hausaufgaben machen oder
irgendwie sowas also und da möchte ich
jetzt nicht irgendwelche wildfremde
leute nichts gegen euch aber die ich
halt nicht mehr kenne die möchte ich da
nicht so gern drin haben also skype nein
und ich dieser kontrast der fck das bin
ich nicht
naja zweite frage womit nimmst du
eigentlich auf da gibt es verschiedene
dinge und zwar nehme ich mit fraps meine
den bildschirm auf und den ingame sound
mit auch das city meine stimme wegen dem
bug wegen meinem dingens hier wegen
meinem rohde nt 1a was ich hier habe ist
das ja ein monoton mikrofon monoton
mikrofon also ein mono mikrofon und das
kann ich nur mit ihm aufnehmen und nicht
mit dingen wie zum beispiel raps mais
raps kano stereomikrofon erkennen naja
danach haben wir dann zwei dateien und
die packe ich dann in premiere packt
dann noch musik hinter anmerkungen intro
alles möglich also die nachbearbeitung
ist eigentlich das einzig schwierige und
danach noch das amt melder ganz normal
mit photoshop so die dritte frage welche
hardware hast du also ich würde einfach
mal sagen ich fange bei der tastatur an
und zwar habe ich eine roccat isku mit
der ich relativ gut eigentlich zufrieden
bin
kann ich ebenso empfehlen die klackert
halt ein bisschen wenn ich jetzt ein
bisschen power hört ihr das
also wenn ich da ein bisschen dollar
drauf drumherum
dann hörte dass schon teilweise in der
aufnahme aber so normal findet
eigentlich ganz gut ich habe eine razer
mamba maus das war einfach dass ich mit
dieser gekauft habt nicht weil ich
unbedingt so ein fetter gamer bin und
alles zocke eigentlich komplett im
gegenteil nur ich hatte davor schon vier
mäuse und hat diesen alle wenn wir nach
drei monaten kaputt gegangen obwohl ich
damit nicht schrecklich um gekommen bin
deswegen habe ich einfach mal so eine
razer mamba gekauft und mit der bin ich
eigentlich auch ganz gut zufrieden
dann habe ich wir alle wissen rohde nt
1a mit dem ich meine stimme aufnehme da
habe ich dann ein paar einstellungen
drangenommen zum beispiel ich habe extra
xlr kabel dafür nicht das komische was
bei der lieferung dabei war das wie
komisch und ich haben ein anderes
gekauft noch ein paar extra sachen dann
habe ich ein behringer mischpult wo ich
auch alle ganz viele knöpfchen hab ich
glaube commander krieger hatten
ähnliches und da habe ich als ein paar
einstellungen übernommen beziehungsweise
mir so ein paar sachen da eingestellt
deswegen klingt meine stimme jetzt auch
besser als in den ersten videos die ich
auf youtube vor einem jahr gemacht hatte
weil da hatte ich noch dass logitech g35
das nämlich jetzt zurzeit immer nur noch
mein headset und nicht mein mikrofon
sondern damit wäre ich einfach nur die
musik und die den ingame sound
ich habe noch einen imac zudem komme ich
aber gleich und ich habe noch einen
samsung syncmaster es a350 das ist mein
zweiter bildschirm dann direkt hier die
vierte frage was für einen pc hast du
wie ich schon gesagt ein imac von 2012
von herten quatsch von 2010 oder 11 oder
irgendwie so dann ist er da raus
gekommen
ursprünglich hat der 4 gb ram ich hab
ihn aber mit 12 gb in der 21 zoll
version mit einer richtig schlechten
grafikkarte also die kam nicht den comic
etwa shader model konnten eigentlich so
fast gar nicht die kraft sogar bei
battlefield ein wenn ich das irgendwie
auf 1080 stelle und nicht im
fenstermodus spiele also ist total
schrecklich wie kann ich dich erreichen
normale belange wie zb fragen über jetzt
so was was ich jetzt gerade kläre oder
allgemeine fragen zum beispiel neuer bad
kommt oder irgendwelche anderen fragen
bitte per pn und per e mail
meine e mails kontrast gmail.com also
gmail.com dort bitte nur so ich sag mal
business sachen bzw irgendwie
lizenzen oder irgendwie sowas er nämlich
da fragt da wirklich alles was ihr mich
wirklich fragen wollten per pn schreiben
und das was mir so ich sag mal wenn ich
irgendwie ein projekt mit mir machen
wollt oder wenn ihr da wirklich eine
tolle idee hat nicht einfach nur l macht
mit mir sondern wenn du wirklich tolle
ideen habe dafür bin ich immer offen
einfach per email schreiben
und ja sechste frage kann ich mal mit
dir spielen
nein eigentlich ist das nicht möglich
weil ich das nicht so gerne mache weil
wenn ich auf servern bin ist das oft so
dass mir dann 20 leute hinterher rennen
und das möchte ich einfach nicht das ist
auch so wenn ich bei sowie games dort
auf dem server bin da war ich letztens
darauf da hat man hunger games gespielt
mit 20 anderen leuten um 10 von den
anderen leuten rennen dir wirklich
hinterher töten dich direkt am anfang
das ist ziemlich blöd das mache ich
nicht so gerne deswegen poste ich auch
keine ip
aber ich denke ich werde in zukunft
irgendwann ips bei twitter posten und
twitter link es in der beschreibung oder
halt auch bei facebook ist auch in der
beschreibung
und dann könnt ihr da einmal abdecken
wenn ihr mit mir spielen wollt siebte
frage was sind deine lieblingsspiele ich
spiele fast gar nicht ich bin jetzt
kommen wir wieder zum im alltag zu
sprechen wurde den habt ihr mittlerweile
auch satt ich bin in der schule denke
ich so immer bis 4 uhr danach dann sport
ungefähr so von von halb fünf bis sechs
und danach habe ich jetzt in letzter
zeit auch dreimal die woche immer
fahrschule weil ich zurzeit meinen
führerschein machen vorher ihr wisst ich
bin 16 und wert in ein paar monaten 17
und nun darf ich endlich ist mit der
theorieprüfung anfangen oder kataster
schrecklich ich muss eben meine 14
stunden da voll kriegen und hat deswegen
jetzt drei mal einer woche fahrschule
und habe da wirklich sehr wenig zeit für
youtube geschweige denn für zocken
zocken tue ich mittlerweile gar nicht
mehr ich letztes jahr immens viel aber
dieses und letztes schuljahr aber diese
schule wollte ich einfach die
prioritäten bisschen anders setzen mehr
lernen
allgemein so mehr ich sag mal
wenn ich so die zeit wenn ich eigentlich
gesagt hätte dann mehr ihn wieder eine
runde joggen oder dann mal ein referat
vorbereiten oder gar keine ahnung
fahrschule jetzt zum beispiel und
allgemein auch ich bin jetzt in der
oberstufe bzw
ich komme immer näher zum abi und das
wird immer heftiger mit klausuren und
soweit davon daher zog ich eigentlich
fast gar nicht aber wenn ich zocke dann
natürlich minecraft wenn ich aufnehme
sonst hatte ich das eigentlich auch fast
gar nicht mehr
und sonst liebe ich in letzter zeit team
fortress 2 finde ich total witzig und
fifa 13 aber fifa 13 ist es so seit fifa
nur sechs spiele ich einfach immer wenn
ich langeweile hat fifa wenn freunde da
sind wir machen jetzt auf das aber fifa
turniere das einmal so viel 56 freunde
zu mir kommen uns sagt man einfach
vielfalt und so dass eigentlich ganz
witzig und über achte frage machen wir
mal ein theater bekomme ich e mails oft
nein weil wenn ich mit dir machen würde
mit dir mit der person die da mich
gerade fragt zum beispiel dann würden
50.000 andere person einkommen ok dazu
vertriebenen würden irgendwie so 100
andere leute ankommen würden sagen hey
du hast mit denen gemacht macht mit mir
auf uns das total unfair idee abo
dislike und so weiter ich mag bratwurst
irgendwie sowas keine ahnung und das war
einfach total ungerecht wenn ich
deswegen wenn ich mit einem von euch
machen würde dann müsste ich so mit
anderen machen aber ich denke ich werde
irgendwann ja ich poste dann ja server
apps bei twitter uns und dann denke ich
könnte dann auch mal einfach so
mitspielen oder halt wenn es bald live
streams gibt dann könnt ihr auch mal
mitspielen oder so aber erstmal nicht
eigentlich neunte und letzte frage für
dieses erste faq hast du einen zweiten
kanal ja da werde ich immens oft gefragt
ob ich einen zweiten kanal hat und da
muss ich wirklich immer den link
schreiben das ist youtube.com / konz
block der ist oben in der beschreibung
bzw irgendwo in der beschreibung und da
einfach mal vorbeischauen dort werde ich
in zukunft auch meine meinung videos
hochladen wie zum beispiel zu julias
blog elfter september oder zu ganz
vielen anderen sachen minecraft update
politik und so was alles ausführlich
erklärt und meine meinung dazu wirklich
meine meinung nur wohnt ja da einfach
mal vorbeischauen ich denke da findet
jeder irgendwas in zukunft und ja ich
würde sagen das was man mit dem ersten
faq
ich will mich mal daumen hoch freuen
dafür dass ich mir jetzt mal hier so ein
paar sachen
euch gesagt habe sage ich mal und wenn
ihr wollt könnt ihr noch weitere fragen
die kommentare schreiben ich weiß nicht
ob ich da in zukunft noch mehrere folgen
machen werde von dem faq vielleicht wenn
ihr noch ein paar andere fragen übrig
sind
und da muss ich dann einfach mal schauen
ob ich da raus sonnerat serie mache dann
würde ich erst mal sagen wir sehen uns
dann eventuell im nächsten faq oder
erstmal im nächsten video zschau